we were delighted to bring this seminar
presented by lab roots welcome everyone
thank you for joining us for today's
keynote presentation titled interplay
between LR our k2 protein kinase and
Ravin ATP ASE's in Parkinson's disease
it's my pleasure to introduce you to dr.
Dario Alessi dr. Alessi is the professor
of signal transduction at the University
of Dundee he obtained his PhD from the
University of Birmingham in the United
Kingdom and carried out his postdoctoral
at the University of Dundee where he was
then appointed the director of the MRC
protein phosphorylation unit in 2012 for
a complete biography on our speaker
please visit the tab at the top of your
screen if any questions arise during the
presentation we encourage you to submit
them in the Q&A box our speaker will
respond back to you via email as a
reminder this presentation is
educational and offers free continuing
education credits click on the
continuing education credits tab located
in the top right corner of the
presentation window and follow the
process to obtain your credits now
please join me in welcoming dr. Alessi I
will now turn the presentation over to
him okay well thank you very much I'd
like to thank lab roots with a very kind
opportunity to give this talk to you I
never tell you about the work that my
the board has been doing on on the on
this protein kinase termed lor k2 and
you know its role in Parkinson's disease
so you know maybe before I get going
with my talk I just wanted to give you a
you know please background about what
I'm interested in you know I'm really
interested in understanding signaling
pathways how they're organized how they
sense a signal and how the signal
travels you know through the signaling
pathway to elicit a physiological effect
and you know we're especially interested
in descriptions in signaling pathways or
components of signaling pathways that
are linked to to human disease
and our hope is that when we understand
these pathways and in well enough detail
this gives us you know clues on how we
can play the engineer by working with
clinicians and pharmaceutical companies
to design potentially new togs that will
restore normality to these signaling
pathways that could be you know new ways
to you know better treat or even cure
disease you know in the in the future so
the story I'm going to tell you about
today
you know concerns you know Parkinson's
disease at the time I think the story
starts in 2004 at the time when I was
really working on signaling pathways
involved and high regulating human blood
pressure and also cancer and I was I was
very interested in in two papers that
you know were published by the groups of
Thomas gasser and Angelo single-turn
their promise back to back at the same
time in 2004 when they reported that
mutations in an NMR key and a protein
kinase turned lrk to that I hadn't heard
of before you know really were causing
you know a rare form of autosomal
dominance Parkinson's disease in the
families of patients that you know that
they had identified and you know this
was actually for me I remember thinking
about the time I was was really curious
and interesting and I remember thinking
you know how can I be tasting and
announce study protein kinase really you
know cause you know Parkinson's disease
so no because I'm immersed in the kinase
and signaling pathways we thought we
would start to program to to understand
our our k2 and how it was regulated and
how mutations might you know be linked
to to to Parkinson's disease so you know
our key to it turns out is one of the
largest protein kinase errs that is
encoded in the human genome is it has
over 2,500 amino acids it has no several
domains as an armadillo domain and
anchoring epi domain at Lucy Neelix
lipids and at the c-terminus as a wd-40
domain but in the distant it also has
two catalytic domains obviously has a
kind
domain but it also has next to the
kinase domain AG gpas domain that you
know binds gtp and hydrolyzes GTP to gdp
and this GTA's domain belongs to an
ancestral family of the GT pas the
maintenance founded even in bacteria
that's called the work poor domain so
you know in humans there's sort of seven
really clear-cut pathogenic mutations
that cause Parkinson's disease and
interestingly these are always located
in the catalytic domains of lrk - either
in the kinase domain or you know the gtp
s domain and and the most common
mutation in humans is G 2019 s so this
is why I've highlighted this you know
you know in large font so before I tell
you about a little more about lrk - I
would like to just give you a very brief
background in Parkinson's disease so
Allah
you know Parkinson's diseases it's the
second most common neurodegenerative
disorder after Alzheimer's disease it's
affects around 10 million people in the
world you know affected by Parkinson's
disease and you know severe debilitating
disease that affects you know firstly
every aspect of people's life who have
this you know this condition and
unfortunately all the current treatments
that we have for this disease just you
know alleviate the symptoms but you know
judo slow down the progression of the
disease so you know and for example the
most widely used talk to treat
Parkinson's disease the talk called Eva
doper this leads to you know it's
converged to dopamine so mimics the loss
of dopamine and you know in the brain
but this is a very old target was
discovered over fifty two years ago you
know in 1967 and unfortunately most of
the the talks that have been developed
since then I really offer incremental
benefits over levodopa they're just
similar to dopamine producing drugs but
maybe you know
meaning in a different manner but
there's a really very critical need for
drugs that you know slow the progression
of the disease down and I hope is by
studying components like hello arcade
shooters are genetically linked to
Parkinson's disease so we know that the
cause of the disease and the patients
that have other rk2 mutations is is is
is is an impact on lor k2 bites women
biology then this gives us a unique
opportunity to maybe develop the first
you know disease modifying you know
treatments by targeting lrk to so I'll
tell you a little bit more about lor k2
and Parkinson's disease so it turns out
that Telemark reaches one of the most
commonly mutated genes that causes
Parkinson's disease so if you have
Parkinson's disease of the budding in
your family you have around five to ten
percent chance that the the gene that
will be mutated is his lor k2 so it's
actually one of the most common disease
causing mutations and and people tell me
that's in about 1% of sporadic
Parkinson's disease patients you know
that there's lor k2 mutations are
observes you know it's 95 percent or
more patients who have Parkinson's
disease have this Braddock form of the
condition in which we don't know what
the cause of the disease is and it
doesn't seem to necessarily be inherited
form um you know from your parents so
the second thing is that the disease
progression with out of our k2 mediated
Parkinson's disease is very similar to
the sporadic form of the disease so the
patients tend to get the disease and
they're 50 60 70 s sort of later on in
life this is normally the disease course
of the disease and clinically this
there's no way to to distinguish the
patients with inner rk2 to live in
Parkinson's disease in terms of their
clinical presentations it's virtually
identical to patients with it
go adding for more of the disease and
95% of people with other RK 2 mutations
apparently have this G 2019 s mutation
that's located within the the kinase
domain of ll RK 2 so you know what's
unique about lor k2 is that all seven
pathogenic mutations you know induce
hyper activation of the yellow arcades
through protein kinase therefore you
know increases its activity and and this
is probably unique in the field of new
generation that the disease can be
caused by in a simple activation of an
enzyme like a protein kinase and
therefore this really offers a very
unique opportunity to you know develop
inhibitors that in his suppressor lrk to
activity to reduce its activity and as a
potential treatment for Parkinson's
disease at least the Parkinson's disease
that is driven by you know ll RK 2
mutations and you know many companies
and then the recent years have been
working on inhibitors for other RK to
potentially the company this most
advanced in this area as a company
called Denali therapeutics who've
recently completed the phase one a and
also phase one P clinical trial where
volunteers healthy volunteers but as
well as as well as humans with with
Parkinson's disease who were given two
drugs that this companies developed and
you know the company claims that in
these humans they were there to
demonstrate that the drugs the mother
compounds is reduced and of our k2
activity by ninety percent and most
importantly the compounds were well
tolerated when given to the healthy
volunteers and also to to to Parkinson's
patients so as I said before other
likely to make might only account for 1%
of Parkinson's patients so an important
question is whether or not head of our
k2 is involved in patients with sporadic
Parkinson's disease and
you know we don't really have the answer
to this question but even the teller
arcade to driven disease is very similar
to the sporadic disease there's there's
a possibility that at least some
patients with a sporadic disease the
disease could be caused by over
activation of the other rk2 pathway and
therefore this might suggest it and you
know ll RK 2 inhibitors might benefit
patients beyond those just carrying ll
RK 2 mutations so you know this is going
to be an important area or for future
you know research so when you work on an
approaching kinase you know the key
question is what is a cellular
substrates of this enzyme and I think
Ellen are key to is probably one of the
hardest problems I've ever worked with
we know we started working on this in
2004 and it took us till 2016 to
identify the key physiological substrate
for this enzyme and I think the reasons
for this were because we are elomar key
to itself as they load catalytic
activity so the substrates if a
sporulate surface for later to a very
low level
we also made knock out and a knock in
mice that mimicked the disease and we
also used chemical inhibitors from
pharmaceutical companies and it's
possible that the chemical inhibitors we
use some publishing companies had a lot
of off-target effects so when we did the
mass spectrometry we saw lots of hits
beyond you know the the true substrates
also when you generate another arcade
should not come out so another arcade
should knock in Mouse mimicking the
disease-causing mutations you probably
discover many pathways you know in a
Cell and tissues and overtime li you get
rewiring of signaling pathways to
compensate for the loss of ll arcade to
the discussions in the LOL k2 pathway
and therefore you see many indirect
effects that also mask that needle in
the haystack from when you do the
genetic experiments so to overcome this
problem what we decided to do was to to
to to to generate sand inhibitor
resistance meat
Jason you know that that made ll RK to
maintain this normal catalytic activity
but major resistance to the chemical
inhibitor that were using there was a
compound terms Emily - that was provided
by the merck pharmaceutical company so
we identified the mutation in an arcade
shooter made as a lark actual assistance
to do to the American hibbott er and
then we made a knockin Mouse to mimic
this mutation and then we made cells
from this knock in mice that we could
study and hear the cell the knockin
cells will be identical to the wild-type
cells because the mutation we chose
doesn't change the other arcade -
activity and the only difference is that
that occurs is when you add the
inhibitor to both the wild-type and the
knocking cells then you're looking for
things that are inhibited in the
wild-type cells but not the inhibitor
assistants knock in cells and you know
by doing these you know very laborious
experiments and then their mass
spectrometry for the for these
experiments was undertaken by Martin
Steiger and it was based in matthias -
in the board's free you know the key set
of substrates that were identified were
include a small subgroup of lab GC
piezas where we were able to demonstrate
that lrk to phosphorylate these enzymes
right in the middle of the switch -
binding motif this is the area here
that's sewn in blue this is the key
business end of the gtp ASA binds to
physiological effectors and you know and
so now you know where proteins are
really very fundamental proteins that
regulate you know all aspects of you
know cell biology or mystical or
trafficking membrane integrity you know
it's controlled by a group of about
seventy nabbed gtp aces and and you know
and so I just wanted to show you and
they will work by binding to you know
gtp and verse and the hydrolyzes GTP to
gdp and then when they're active or when
they're bound to gtp and they can
interact with you know
factor proteins by using this switch to
you know docking interacts and sides so
I just want to show you some data to to
really demonstrate that you know that
sort of RG CPAs is like grab ten I'll
indeed physiological substrates for for
lor k2 so here we use a gel where it
separates out it's called the first tag
gel there separates out the
phosphorylated lab from the
dephosphorylation lab and so in the
upper band you can see a few percents
one maybe two percent of the lab protein
is phosphorylated and when you add the
MLI to ll RK 2 inhibitor when you get to
those of clean Animoto inhibitor you can
see that the RAB protein is d
phosphorylated and and then we did the
same experiments with the you know these
eight to one sixty knock in cells these
are the cells that are now resistant to
the ml i to inhibitor because this
mutation you know reduces the ability of
NRK to to be inhibited by ml i to and
you can see here now you have to go to a
hundred animal inhibitor to induce the
dephosphorylation or you know of the rat
protein so you know this really
persuaded us that the wraps were the the
key substrates for you know for the lor
k2 pathway and then we were then the
next question was was whether the
disease-causing pathogenic mutations
would enhance the lab protein
phosphorylation because you would think
of the harvest were the relevant
substrates for heather arcade to that
the nokia mutations that cause as
Parkinson's disease would enhance the
phosphorylation and then this is what we
found for example this is the are one
for for one gene mutation as present in
the gtp a stir made for me against cells
with this knockin you taste and you can
see you can secrete a four-fold
increased levels of lab 10
phosphorylation and when you add the
other arcane 2 inhibitor in this case
we're using a GSK compounds you induce
completely phosphorylation of there are
potent so these these experiment
suggests
that you know grabs that you have
telling where the physiological
substrates and the disease-causing
mutations all led to an enhancement of
the of the lab activity of the lab
phosphorylation and so it turns out that
there's this phosphorylation site were
identified in the lab GTP ages it's
actually found in them in about fifty of
the seventy lab protein so next question
was you know how common is which subset
of the lab proteins are phosphorylated
by other our k2 so we're there for her
to test very carefully all 15-hour
proteins that had a phosphorylation
sites in this particular sequence in us
in his switch to motif and then for
those that which we first tested listen
ANOVA expressed experiments in two nine
three cells and for those that we found
worthless for elated with ended
secondary experiments to look at the
endogenous proteins and thus far we
think that there's about 30 of our
proteins that's a probably genuine
physiological substrate for lor k2 this
is our ones there are fees the rabbits
the ten twelve twenty nine thirty five
and forty three for these labs we have a
lead evidence that the endogenous
protein is regulated by lor k2 so when
you knock it out you lose the
phosphorylation or when you inhibited
you use the phosphorylation but when you
have a knockin mutation that mimics the
Parkinson's disease causing mutation you
enhance the phosphorylation of these of
the of these grab proteins so the next
days of the work was to you know was to
use a was was to us to generate you know
monoclonal antibodies that would enable
us to better recognize and detect and RK
to phosphorylate SIDS or our proteins
these are really the the beacons of
Ellen R K choose pathway activity you
know in tissues and in cells so it's
very critical that we cannot identify
these sites and measure them actually so
we spend lots of time working with the
Michael J Fox foundation and AB camera
and generated
longest of antibodies I think we're
posting over 30 antibodies now that
we've identified that can detect and
immunoblot immunoprecipitate and and
could be used to be immunofluorescence
as well as also facts analysis to study
the ll RK - phosphorylated forms of the
lab proteins and you know these are
wonderful reagents for example the the
antibody that picks up for about ten if
you use a cell like the fibroblast cell
you can see you and you have one major
protein that's detected in the whole
extract that you know goes down when you
add another rk2 inhibitor and you know
and we can use these reagents to study
more globally how pathogenic mutations
affect grab protein phosphorylation for
example we found that the g20 19's
mutation knock in mice
it was around at one point eight fold
increasing in the end of our protein
phosphorylation
whereas mutations in the the our one
four four one residues give around three
point five to four fold increase in our
protein phosphorylation and when you use
lor key two knockouts themselves you see
no map coating phosphorylation and when
you use kinase and active knocking MEF's
that were provided to us by GSK you also
see no phosphorylation of the you know
of the RAB protein so you know as I said
before we've made a lot of these
different antibodies and I'm not going
to go through all of them but a lot of
them that we're working on have been
made unlisted here and you know we think
that these will be very important
reagents for the field to to study an
RKG pathway biology and we've been very
careful to make sure that the antibodies
are immediately released to to to to to
to these commercial companies as soon as
they characterize so that the whole
battlefield including pharmaceutical
companies can benefit from you know you
know from this from this world so
another next question for us is okay we
know there
to phosphorylates these are proteins in
the middle of this effective binding
motif but how is this going to affect
the next stage of the pathway you know
downstream of the pathway and you know
and then it seems to see it seems to me
that since only a few percent of though
of the of the lab proceeding was was
phosphorylated the most likely way that
this would work would be that the
phosphorylated lab would would act as a
receptor for a new set of proteins that
can only interact with the lrk to
phosphorylated form of the protein so
we've conducted a lot of work to
identify proteins that might only bind
to the other rk2 phosphorylated form of
the lab proteins and my lab and also the
lab level of Mateus manual also run by
Martin Steiger did a lot of you know
mass spectrometry to to to look for such
you know receptors for sporulate is
about proteins and and that's why we've
been really focused or debating about 10
and we've identified you know four
proteins called little l1 l2 [ __ ] 3 and
JIP four that have a you know have a i
hate's to domain in the you know it you
know in the in the sequence that we've
been able to show binds very selectively
to the you know lrk to force for related
form of the proteins and and this in
other words we don't suggest that the
following model of how this this pathway
might work so one of the labs are made
obviously they live on membranes but
originally they are moving there there
that they can move between membranes by
forming a complex with you know the gist
EDI codes and it's a chaperone protein
that binds to most route proteins and
sort of solubilizes these grab proteins
so they can be moved between membrane
structures and in the cell and then
they'll be taken to a membrane where
they'll sit on the membrane and then
then they and their pen elated see
terminus is shown with this squiggle is
critical for maintaining the labs
the membranes and the labs will be
enacted but this will be bound to the
gdp-bound form but in a response to a
signal or an agonist this the SCAF
protein here will will will come along
and switch on the RAB is by converting
it into the gtp-bound form this
gtp-bound form them will bind to many
effectors to regulate normal membrane or
visa called biology but what happens
when NMR k2 comes in lor kids who will
phosphorylate the RAB at this switch to
motif and this world block its ability
to bind and effective protein because
most of the effectors we tested can no
longer bind to the haps once they're
phosphorylated and therefore these
effects will dissociate from the lab
proteins and therefore the
phosphorylated high protein at first
will be completely naked intact at the
at the membrane it is phosphorylates
because they combine into GDI
so he can build to another membrane in
the cell but then what happens is that
these other effects of proteins that can
only bind to the phosphorylated
effectors like the au poivre one lil
culture gypsy inject for you know come
in they can bind to the phosphorylated
labs and you know trigger just winging
distinct downstream biology so you know
obviously a key a key part of our
projects now is to really understand how
these these effector proteins
you know regulates you know about
biology and we think we've only
identified four of them but we think
there'll be many more and we're setting
up screens to you know identify novel
defectors that will bind to the other
our k2 force for related proteins and in
collaboration with the labboard live
american and then a postdoc in his lab
is here ET ER whose boots we've been
able to crystallize phosphorylated of
our bades
bound to the our hayes to domain of of
little pale tooth and the stalks are
showing here and what's quite nice as
you can see specific residues that are
involved such as the odds need 132 as a
junior pal to that's really physical for
coordinating interaction
with the lor k2 phosphorylated abates
and when you mutate these residues you
lose the ability of the chilli powder to
bind to phosphorylated evades protein
and you know my great collaborator Susan
feather who works at the University of
Stanford has has done some beautiful
work to study the role that this
interaction between real purl 1 and
about 10 plays in cells and her
laborious we have shown that this hoodie
sort of plays an important part in the
part plays an important role in the
pathway that regulates sitio genesis and
you know need when you have lrk to
pathogenic mutations you know she was
able to demonstrate this this leads to
an inhibition of cilia genesis and this
can be restored by inhibiting lor k2 or
the cilia genesis to come back and in
this pathway that really does require
the interaction of little bell to
binding to phosphorylated about 10 to
get this inhibition effect on cydia
genesis so goodbye other rk2 and and
then the faithful arm was able to so
that's in you know especially in the
striatum in the cholinergic neurons and
the brain there this inhibition of the
city genesis pathway it leads to a
reduced response to sonic hedgehog
signals and this internal you know
reduces the newer protective g TNF
signaling that comes back to the
dopaminergic neurons and this could
really underline you know potentially
the you know being face death or loss or
you know or degeneration of dopaminergic
neurons and potentially links lor k22 to
Parkinson's disease so you know there's
more work to be done here but this isn't
sort of one model a body that explains
how weather our case you might be linked
to to to Parkinson's disease then our
next question is what is upstream of lor
k2 and how is it regulated and to do
this we we've really thought that there
may be one way to start was maybe
tastings in one of the other twenty or
so genes that cause Parkinson's disease
maybe mutations in these genes could
could also switch so on lor k2 and
increase have ten phosphorylation and
this could be the mechanism by which
these these mutations are linked to you
know Parkinson's disease so what we're
doing now is we're testing many of these
mutations to see whether the influence
you know about ten phosphorylation you
know a few years ago when you first
started to have twenty nine and then
this works all published so you know and
this is also collaboration with Susan
feathers lab and as who say that the
Laborde Slee a boundary west and mark
fiction and then the board trees in
Japan got very similar results where you
know we show all showed that no map 29
is located at the golgi Network and it
somehow interacts with the n-terminal
domain abettor rk2 so especially when
lor k2 has the GT has them as the
pathogenic mutations in the GT pas
domain that's actually increased
gtp-binding yellow marketers recruited
to the golgi where it becomes activated
and you can see the activation by
looking at the enhanced phosphorylation
that we have 10 or the phosphorylation
of itself as Syrian 1292 all have 29 you
know this phosphorylates the field in 71
and you know this is a very robust
without that you you can see very
clearly with other expression studies at
least but we still more work is still
really needed to understand how have 29
interacts with lor k2 and especially how
this activation occurs you know there
may be other components that might be
needed at the membrane to achieve this
because it in so far it has not been
reproduced you know in an in vitro
experiments in a test tube
the second component we studied is this
V PS 35 components that you know V PS 35
it's it's a very
cool components of a complex called the
red slimmer complex that's made of three
subunits is God's bps 35 here shown in
red is for the second component called
bps 29 and the third component called
bps 26 and this acts as a critical cargo
binding and settling component that
takes cargo from the endosomes and small
vesicles to the golgi and also it takes
things from the endosomes to the plasma
membrane and it so plays a very physical
role in you know cargo shuttling you
know in in this cell and you know what's
interesting actually is that the you
know the the cargo marked in the diagram
where the cargo buying typically to
direct or more complex but you'll see on
my slide there's there's an aspartic
acid 620 residue that's highlighted and
this residues in a region of the Rexall
complexes whose function is unknown but
when this residues mutates to an
asparagine has a Jew this causes you
know very severe autosomal dominant
inheritance ins disease and my patients
with this mutation tend to get the
disease at least 10 years before
patients about on RK 2 mutations and it
also seems to be more penetrance it
seems adversity every patients with an
area as 620 n you taste and VPS 35
developers Parkinson's disease whereas
this this isn't necessarily the case for
lrk to show so we was we wanted to see
whether or not this bps 35 620 m
mutation you know could you know in fact
lrk to activity about 10 phosphorylation
so we go hold him a knockin mouse that
had been made with this mutation I think
it was originally made by the Michael J
Fox foundation on Matt Farah's
lithography and we made cells from from
these mice
what we found was it we got the same
results in the cells and also tissues of
the mouse that we looked at we saw a
very dramatic enhancements in in lab
aids that I obtained about 12 or
sporulation in the cells that had this
bps 35 620 n mutation and when you had
the other RK 2 inhibitor you know that
this phosphorylation goes away telling
us that the mutation is leading to
enhanced phosphorylation of these are
proteins but we don't know the mechanism
here what mechanism is it could be that
this mutation is activating lor k 2 so
the RK 2 is more active and therefore
force paul-etta's Rab substrates more
effectively or it could be somehow
beginning the ramps and the other
arcades you together or putting them
together in the same vesicles more
efficiently than the non mutated form of
PPS 35 Libby put I love arcade shoe and
the wraps together on the same physical
maybe you'll get enhanced force for
Eliza but I should also say that the
increase in the rap for sporulation we
see it in this in these cells and also
tissues from the mice is much more than
we see with a you know with with with an
arcade to pathogenic mutations which
given by the most three to fourfold
increase in lab force for this and
where's the bps 35 is giving us five to
eight fold increased phosphorylation so
it's possible that this explains why if
you know
bps 35 patients with these mutations
maybe develop Parkinson's disease
earlier and the small penance ones if
the other arcade two activity is more
elevated in these patients so you know
my work then we're also interested to
see whether we could interrogate and I
mark a two activity in in patients
whether with the VPS 35 mutations so
this project was was large determined by
my clinical collaborators Estes Amla and
Francesco man aboard smear and we also
collaborated extensively with
Alexander's inputs at the University of
Vienna and his colleagues and now
exactly how they
20 patients who have these VPS 35
mutations and we just really wants to
ask the question is that we could be
demonstrating these people that they had
enhanced our protein phosphorylation so
to do this we developed an assay using
monocytes or also neutral thoughts that
we isolate from the blood of these
patients obviously the places where the
mutaters have the mutations and every
cells but and then we just wanted to
test whether this mutation in the in the
monocyte in the lor k2 would lead to an
enhanced there are protein
phosphorylation so so these are the
experiments that we did in monocytes we
had as a control a number of idiopathic
Parkinson's patients and we liked those
as the control because we knew these
patient students have mutations in bps
35 where our rk2
they're the same age as the patients
with the DP s 35 mutations and then on
the same medication and then when we
purify the monocytes we take the plus
and minus knell of our k2 inhibitor and
we lyse the cells and we've lost four
foster lab ten and we also brought four
total levels of website see if you look
at the total levels of grabbed tennis
it's quite remarkable
it needs some of these donors or
individuals you can see the levels of a
very very constant if you look at the
levels of other RK - they're very
constant and then the levels are bps
35:26
are also very constant between you know
between the difference individuals and
in the indian Pathak basis you can see
the you know significance 10
phosphorylation and when you add as you
expect the other of arcades who never
took the the phosphorylation goes down
to the background levels so this proves
to us that we are measuring ll RK -
mediated arctan phosphorylation
but what's quite striking you can see
here the three idiopathic basins the
three patients with the bps 35 mutations
you can see it at three to fourfold
enhancements in how protein
phosphorylation that goes down with the
ll RK 2 inhibitor suggesting that we see
the same results in patients with bps 35
mutations as we
in in a mouse model and I think Esther
and Alexander have now analyzed I think
nearly 20 patients with VPS 35 we
chasers and we see in all these patients
this you know very robust elevated lab
10 for you know phosphorylation and then
assassins now being widely used to
interrogate you know Ellen arcade sure
activity you know in humans and you know
it's a very simple way to assess whether
every taste know another disruption of
biology is it is increasing lab 10
phosphorylation you know in a in a human
patient so I'll now go on to before I
Dennis with VPS 35 I just wanted to
highlight that we've been working with
stress mark Biosciences and you know
some of the VPS 35 antibodies were using
ones you know very high quality so we
developed two fabulous antibodies that
picked up bps 35 that are listed here
and their validates because when you
knock out the VPS 35 using CRISPR
methodology you lose recognition of the
bps 35 protein and we've also validated
these antibodies working of
immunofluorescence so you know in the
wild-type cells you can see these they
read part I located around the cells
that these are the small vesicles that
the bps 35 is located in but when you
knock out the the VPS 35 you lose these
these pound size these musical acicular
structures so manie's we will test every
single available bps 35 antibody and
then these two antibodies are vastly
superior in our opinion than any other
antibody that has been developed so I
would recommend if you work in bps 35
that you test these antibodies so as I
said before we don't know the mechanism
by which this mutation and bps 35
stimulates of a metallic phosphorylation
without protein phosphorylation this is
only in
important area of research the lab is to
you know try to you know work this this
conundrum hours so the next one for part
and I'll tell you about is you know the
world lol arcades who plays in the
immune system so it turns out that ugly
tumors most highly expressed in humans
in in immune cells is much higher than
monocytes and neutrophils macrophages
and for example the manatees in in
neurons and the brain is also quite
highly expressed in astrocytes or
microglia and oligodendrocytes but it's
normally quite low in in euros and you
know so therefore because of this
expressive pattern people wondered
whether it had a role to play in
protecting you know the people for
opportunistic infection it by working in
the immune system and you know genetic
analysis has shown that you know gee
wasps analysis and has linked mutations
in lor k22 inflammatory conditions
including a server to colitis clothes
disease and also susceptible subsets
susceptibility to leprosy and in other
studies in mice have shown that you know
mutations that stimulate other rk2
activity you know protects against
Mysterio and Salmonella infection and
vice versa when you knock out a lil RK 2
you know that the mice more prone to
these infections so you know you know
question is whether when you in fact you
know an immune cell or immune cell
recognizes a bacterial or pathogenic
fungi no does this impact the yellow RK
2 signaling pathway so you know we've
done some work with the pathogenic
bacteria but you know there was also I'm
going to tell you about today at the
work we've been doing with you know it's
powerful
you know fungal pathogens and you know
especially the candida and Aspergillus
that's a very common you know
pathogens that affect people especially
people who have you know problems with
their immune system that's a compromise
and know this works been a work with my
collaborator Simon Arthur's lab and
instance and Stephanie lab ah and you
know you even a fan in my lab who have
been working on this project and you
know what we found is when we when we
take these our mouse bone / calf ages
and we infect them with Candida albicans
for example and this can be done even at
an mo io o of one you see that within 30
30 minutes you see a billion of a bust
increase in in lab 10 phosphorylation
that stays in high for up to four hours
around the cells start dying around four
hours but you know it stays high up to
that point and then we know this is
mediated by all of our k2 because when
we add the other RK 2 inhibitor via the
phosphorylation the web 10 is maintained
though so this suggests that like the
bps 35 mutation Candida infection is
somehow bringing lraqi to it allow
proteins together density and on the
same basical and I'm promoting you know
about 10 you know phosphorylation and
and it seems that for this to happen the
candida has to be alive see if you he
kill them or you have experice you've
used the cell wall or you know you know
we don't see this stimulation of lab 10
phosphorylation following infects and
with the heat field
you know Candida albicans and you know
we've seen the similar results with you
know a specialist that infections also
stimulates map 10 phosphorylation by
other arcade to but if you use yeast
visi I you you don't achieve this so
work is ongoing my liability workouts
you know what are the what are the key
mechanisms that that bring Ellen arcade
and our proteins together following
infections and then obviously the most
important question is how important is
this pathway in protecting patients from
you know infection so you know it's
quite a stinger that the model is that
if you have an ll RK - pathogenic
mutation you might be more protected
from you know from against opportunistic
infections and then this would have been
very important hundreds or even
thousands of years ago of people
obviously didn't live must past their
twenties as if you had a mutation to
protected you from developing infection
that's the prime of your immune system
this will lastly be beneficial and but
you know the problem with this is when
you have a primed immune system that
might be good for you when you're young
you know as you get older this might
increase the chances of maybe leading to
newer inflammation or you know and that
might be promoting Parkinson's disease
so this is sort of concept is called
antagonistic pleiotropy something that
might be good for you when you're young
but then becomes detrimental for you as
you get old many sort of signaling
pathways that the cause disease might be
doing this or the protecting people and
they're young you know when they're
young but therefore you know the acne at
the activation of the pathway throughout
life becomes detrimental so the next
thing I'm going to talk to you about is
the is the protein phosphatase that acts
on on the lab protein to D phosphorylate
there are protein you know after lr k2
has put the phosphate on you know all
protein phosphorylation in cells is
normally phosphorylate that is
reversible and the phosphatases work to
do phosphorylates the protein so we
think that the RAB phosphatase is very
active in cells because when you treat
cells with another RK 2 inhibitor you
can see within one minute the protein is
becoming substantially dephosphorylation
as to look completely dephosphorylation
within about five minutes whereas if you
look at another phosphorylation site
another RK to a site called 95
yeah it takes about 80 minutes for it to
become d phosphorylated so you know
we're very curious to understand what is
this very high level of phosphatase
activity that's working or on the lab
proteins and obviously the at least this
enzyme is potentially very important
because this will keep now protein
phosphorylation low in cells maybe you
inhibited it that in levels of lab
phosphorylation which could potentially
increase to to toxic levels so it turns
out that this this little work going on
in the world now I'm quoting
phosphatases most of the work on protein
phosphorylation focuses on the kinase
errs but we now know that there's a
hundred eighty-nine catalytic subunits
or phosphatases they lie within ten
different phosphatase families many of
these catalytic subunits interact with
regulates these subunits so there's
literally probably hundreds if not
thousands of components in the cell
there's regulates protein
dephosphorylation and this is a vastly
under studied field of research so we
undertook Inessa I'll go over the
details we undertook Vanessa RNAi screen
to to knock down all of these
phosphatases individually and also
something known like military subunits
and tallit so the knockdowns we tested
the the impact that this had on on that
protein phosphorylation in the cell and
when we did this clean in two different
ways
you know one way we just looked the the
dephosphorylation of the the
phosphorylation status of the rat
protein after the S RNAi screen in the
second screen we did the S RNAi screen
for 72 hours and then we incubate itself
for five minutes with an L of our k2
inhibitor and we look for you know
phosphatases when we knock down
maintains high levels of lab 10
phosphorylation and then the top hits in
this screen was was an enzyme that is
called ppm one hates a very poorly
studied phosphatases it belongs to this
family of phosphatase as known as the
ppm of magnesium dependents family of
phosphatases in humans we have 20
members of this family and ppm in one
Hayes's belongs to one of them that is
shown here has two relatives at J and M
and it's a very simple phosphatase it
has a phosphatase catalytic domain and
this when you get 514 residues it
doesn't seem to have any other you know
obvious domains in a structure and so
you know to validate ESR and a screen we
made CRISPR knockouts of ppm one hates
we actually made 10 difference
CRISPR cell lines that Saunders remove
all the proteins under and remove the
upper spliced the upper form of ppm one
haze but what we found is that no 10 ppm
one hates
knock out clothes we resulted in an
enhancement of about 10 for sporulation
the scene in these cells
we also found them when we overexpress
ppm one hates in cells we dramatically
inhibitors we have 10 phosphorylation so
what in the knee cells when you
overexpress you know and catalytically
inactive phosphatase known as hates 1 5
3 d you maintain in high levels of RAB
10 phosphorylase but when you express
that the wild-type inactive phosphatase
you are you know dramatically reduce the
degree of of lab 10 phosphorylation i
mean we see the same results with a lot
of other a protein is not just about 10
so we think that ppm one hate is quite
non selective it seems to
dephosphorylation
you know a large group of all our
proteins that are phosphorylated by ll
RK 2 and then is that we think this is a
direct effect because when we take
phosphorylated and i'm ten protein and
we incubated with a wild-type ppm one
hates we can see a time dependent
deformation over grab aids where this is
an in vitro experiments are suggesting
that the ppm one hates works directly on
the on the phosphorylated without
protein
when you do the same experiment with
catalytically inactive proteins you
don't see the phosphorylation and you
know one advance the phosphatases is
that working with prostatitis you can
actually generate what's known as a
substrate scrapping mutants and you can
design the mutant that does the binds to
your phosphorylated substrates but it
can't really be phosphorylated so and
becomes tapped you know onto the
phosphorylated substrates and this is a
very good method for validating
physiological substrates for your
prostates because if you can make the
substrates up in mutants
you can then isolate the substrates hard
traffic mutant from cells and you can
see what else is bound to it and these
are normally sort of the physiological
substrates of the phosphatase so we
identified the substrate are mutants of
the PPM one hates and this is a mutation
called d-28 a tyranny and you can see
when we express this substrates happy
mutants a ppm one hates in cells this is
the 288 a mutants and we amino
precipitate this from cells you can see
the binds to very high affinity with
your endogenous phosphorylated in our
veins and grab 10 whereas if you
overexpress the wild type or another
catholic lee an active mutants a ppm one
hates it's not a substrate our
convictions it doesn't interact with it
so we think this provides the strongest
evidence this you know the the RAB
proteins are genuinely physiological
substrates of the you know ppm one hate
so much work is still going wrong they
really want to understand more about how
ppm one hates activity is regulated and
controls we're going to know whether the
mutations in ppm one hates that might
you know you know increases expressed
maybe protect people from Parkinson's
disease or vice versa if you've got an
inhibition the ppm one hates with this
lead to an increased chance of getting
Parkinson's disease and you know is it
possible that you know to develop
compounds does enhance ppm one hates I
see you know could these potentially be
our you know new agents to Tibetan
sweets you know Parkinson's disease so
in the last few slides I'm going to tell
you about you know some work that we've
been doing to to you know to you know
interrogate better interrogate lol k2 in
humans and some mass spectrometry
analysis that we've been doing to you
know to trying develop more sensitive
and and quantitative assays then the
immunoblotting systems that I've been
discussing and then then to do this this
is again led by aster Samuel Oh together
with the board series of you know
collaborators in this case is from
Barcelona Hospital you know from the
lava bed world of Alonso and you know
his his colleagues and we've been able
to get hold over you know numerous
patients with g20 19's mutations and
also five patients with the r14 for 1g
mutation and by studying the taking
neutrophils form from these individuals
as I've mentioned before we were able to
assess grab ten phosphorylation in the
neutrophils to live develop derive from
these people and then when we do the
experiments with whether we'll the five
people with the I won four for one see
me Jason and this includes three
carriers and two patients with
Parkinsons disease you can see in all
cases we can see robust enhancements of
the lab ten phosphorylation compared to
you know the control donors that you
used for these these patients and then
we've done the same experiments for
patients with the g20 19's
mutation and but in this case this
mutation doesn't seem to increase
obtained for sporulation to to to to a
big enough extent that we can we can
visualize this on on an immunoblot
analysis and this date is shown in this
slide here where we can find that you
know with the with the are 1 4 4 1 gb
Chasen's is easily seen that there's in
Huntsman's intend for sporulation but
with the g20 19's patience there's
really no significant increase in our 10
phosphorylation over the controls
unfortunately so because of this we
decided to develop more robust mass
spectrometry technologies to to to to
look at this so you know here you know
this is a paper which is done by our
collaborators Matthias Malinowski carry
a land and their colleagues at our lab
boards be held to a small extent in you
and you can beat the methodology in this
paper but it's it's a very robust method
to study the stoical immensely of
protein phosphorylation that show you
then is much more sensitive and
quantitative than the immunoblot
analysis
so we've reanalyzed these all these
samples with this more quantitative mass
spectrometry I say but here again we see
the same results as we saw with the
immunoblot analysis that it's not easy
to see an increase in the RAB 10
phosphorylation from the samples divided
from the g20 19's people carriers or
Pacers but as we can still easily see
this increase in the r14 for 1g derived
you know patients so you know I think
that's you know so is the the assay
works and the immunoblotting assay is
not too bad either and then in the last
two or three slides I just wanna tell
you about a new I see them on the boards
we've been setting up this is a
multiplexer see that enables us to study
the phosphorylation of grab one three
eight ten thirty five forty three lraqi
two total levels as well as the
phosphorylation sites of nine ten nine
three five on these sites and to do this
we we are immunoprecipitate cells or
tissue extracts we digest the whole
protein in these extracts to tryptic
peptides and then we amino precipitate
these scripting peptides with a group of
antibodies
that IPS you know the key peptide
antigens that are required to assess the
levels of these proteins we also spike
the extract that the Aquin that heavy
label peptide sweets of these reporters
and and then we are able to do targeted
you know high resolution mass
spectrometry to assess the levels of
these peptides in the samples and you
know by doing this we can now they
easily assess no foster web levels and
ll RK to pathway indicators in you know
in cell extracts and their muscle more
rapid way and quantitative manner then
it can be achieved by doing immunoblot
analysis and this is just one example of
the mass spec acid so and at the bottom
versus the you know the immunoblot
analysis and and then you can with
advances of the mass spectrometry assays
you don't just measure out of ten you
can you measure these are 14 other
readouts that i discussed and you can
see very clearly that other of our
proteins are affected by LRR k2
mutations and you know we think this
assay is going to be you know heavily
used in the future to to assess that ll
RK 2 signaling pathways so I think I'm
nearly running out of time now so I
think I won't go through the rest of my
date I just want to conclude by telling
you that that the pathway we've been
working on is I think we've started to
work out the nuts and bolts of the other
our k2 pathway regulates grab protein
phosphorylation mutations and without 29
MVPs 35 begin to this pathway also with
infection and maybe other environmental
pathways and then the phosphorylated and
our proteins these seems to be the
element that's that there's probably
linked to you know the Parkinson's
disease and and then you know I've also
told you about you know the work of
Susan feathers Laborde Smith and with
cilia Genesis you know is linked to
concerns disease you know through this
real power one signaling pathway this
month of the work in the field has been
done suggest error RK qu regulates the
lysosome or stress and synaptic vesicle
trafficking and then this presents a
mechanism by which the lor k to be can
be linked to parkinson's disease and
there's also this third link with the
immune system by by controlling new
inflammation could be the third way by
what's LOL k2 is as linked to to disease
and then other work in the field has
demonstrated that you know have biology
is likely to lie the hearts of
understanding parkinson's disease you
know this work shows that the pink one
protein kinase that's also implicated in
Parkinson's disease regulates have
phosphorylation two distinct sites ooh
to lrk to the work of the nature's and
link waste is so and there's alpha
synuclein
ability to be toxic in cells you know
and cause you know cell death is is
linked to its ability to interact with
with lab proteins mutations and 39b lab
39b and other proteins by bps 35 bps 13
and DNA jc6 that are also linked to to
our proteins so you know so there's much
more work to be done to understand the
biology of perhaps this is linked to
Parkinson's disease and I just want to
end by acknowledging the large to the
people who've been involved in this work
know in my lab is this has been the work
of Francesca as Elena of a defeat Assad
pavel yen kira and many others over the
years that have been involved in this
work and we've had always a for the last
five or six years very strong and
beautiful collaborations within the
board's we have Matias man and
increasingly Stu Susan Pfeffer at the
University of Stanford our works been
supported tremendously by the Michael J
Fox foundation from the light from the
beginning when we started working with
- you know this collaboration was
critical for success and we've also
received funding from the Medical
Research Council of the UK and
Parkinson's UK and I'd like to thank our
the clinical collaborators including
Alexander Xin plaits for providing
reagents and thank you for your
attention thank you dr. Alessi for that
outstanding presentation for additional
informative presentations your agenda on
herbs page as a final reminder our
speaker will follow up with any
questions you've submitted via email
thank you again for your participation